che succede
no
non ci siamo a scuola guardate simoni
scuola ma la scuola si è
piccoli non fatevi prendere dal panico
gente siamo agenti del dipartimento del
dell'attività criminale
criminale abbiamo ricevuto la notizia di
una scuola che si sta rimpicciolendo e
siamo qui per aiutarvi
la scuola sia rimpicciolita non credo ti
abbiano sentito dire non fatevi prendere
dal panico ed in effetti si è fatta
prendere dal panico no studenti in
queste strane persone hanno ragione non
c'è nulla di cui preoccuparsi ma questo
tipo un alieno è certamente niente di
sinistro malvagio in atto ma dove siamo
finiti questo sito perché nostrani non
si va a scuola è davvero piccolo era o
no adesso
wow
mettetevi comodi lasciati un bel mi
piace prendete qualcosa da bere qualcosa
da mangiare i miei como grasso avventura
abbiamo allora esploriamo intanto o mio
dio con le formiche sono gigantesche
formiche chicago è bravo noi che siamo
piccolissime quindi vediamo le formiche
giganti ad ora già queste tele
succedendo o sei tu sono contento che tu
stia avvenuto ascoltami ti informerà
sulla situazione molto bene come avrai
notato l'intera scuola è stata di
ufficialità noi abbiamo notato
gli studenti sono in preda al panico
dobbiamo sistemare le cose
ok ci siamo abbiamo gente in tutta la
scuola possono fare solo così tanto
abbiamo bisogno del tuo aiuto ok si 20
ago rai conte dalla nostra parte
scopriremo che ha ridotto la scuola è
riportato le cose alla normalità in
pochissimo tempo ok è tradotto con
google translate
contiamo su di te agente speciale rito
[Musica]
speciale i
tuoi occhiali quando i tuoi occhiali
sono bellissimi ei ragazzino ragazzino
maghrebino melanine arcobaleno di pedine
oltre alla porta questo ti metterà in
quella che ci piace chiamare speed mode
o li condivido il parere superveloce
avere un aspetto davvero fantastico
che bello percorrere la scuola ma super
velocità va ad un caduta nell'acqua
grave è nuova a queste scritte già
divertentissima
sempre nell'acqua
credo sfracellata
tu sei riuscito a passare sì solo che mi
sono sfracellato su un ragazzino
a
salire
e bellissimo comunque la super veloci fa
una cosa e giganti ma è fatta benissimo
questo di fruste ora dove devo andare a
scredo
strafigo
ma questa squadra è gigante e
tuttora matite e ora dove devo andare
sì ma senza non cadere dalle matite però
è di girare
verificati
ei per chi al contrario se per chiedere
il bar dare alla parte ma è di far
sì siete veri si ripete un po di volte
che
venga risolto brava
siamo quasi certi che succede fatti
parti gli insetti giganti delle armi e
poi della bowling non possono
intralciare il mondo small vecchio stile
ok maturano tra no e nemmeno tu per la
cronaca devo passare di lì per scoprire
chi ha rimpicciolito la scuola quindi
cerca di non farsi colpire vv dobbiamo
schivare questi palloni
quello è caduto giù bene buona fortuna
ma allora spiegatemi perché questi
alunni ce l'hanno con noi perché questi
studenti ce l'hanno con lui
sono fatto una giocata
di come stai facendo
è un doppio salto basta premere
nuovamente il fatto che
ho visto che visse frase allah vi
evitare di ha superato e allora vediamo
che cosa dice a metà strada continua a
guidare
borsellino sì ma se sta al tipo no
che è figo
non passato guarda ci sono ancora
conformi che ci fanno
che brutte quindi devo saltare
qualcuno si è sfracellato no ma devo
rifare tutto da capo
andiamo a saltare dall'altra parte
tu dove sei io sono già al prossimo lo
stesso basta pausa da ballo obbligatoria
dal governo ma anche di dobbiamo parlare
wow saltando su questo
aspetto non ha capito neanche io posso
aspettare nei colori che voglia mi dici
bene meglio che ti
restano due lato
allora riprova
[Musica]
vitale davanti
no
che succede
[Applauso]
[Musica]
slater
siamo nella mente un panino gigante
sembra che sia scoppiata una grande vita
alimentare qualche subito bruciarvi
corsa in prigione dimenticare la lotta
contro cibo questa è una guerra totale
andiamo ovviamente evitare felicissimo
vediamo chi arriva per primo al panino
gigante
lamento perché quando anziane posso
promettervi con la bocca aperta
bisogna
guardarli
la parola
questo che è un altro giocatore
sono al panino giganti come girassero
civero lo si va al
primo limitare no in oggetto sono qui
per evitare ecco scivolando sulle stesse
le puzze
dai
guai andato a fuoco tutto ci sono nei
forni che sono andati a fuoco o no piano
piano piano piano piano io non so più
dove andare parlate per voi voglio uno
di questi panini giganti
anche le pagine più amati
ecco i fuochi mi sembra quasi o no wow i
panini fanno tipo da tappeto elastico
davvero
eccomi a freddo
doveste alla
città il sopravvento prendi vera la
pittura
proviamo wow sparirò gigante rotolato
vediamo evitare che si faceva
eco vitale laggiù lasciato invidioso per
portare fortuna finale ce la farà
[Musica]
non avete lasciato mi piace sono stati
forse morale che
ci riprovo vediamo da e poi farcela
[Applauso]
per viva imporre convinto non farti
brucia tiene a farlo non mettono dentro
a cui famiglini
fatto e adesso che sul semplice del sud
ma tipo tutto allagato
attento perché il technics fu non
abbiate già andora si no ma nessuno è
scivolato mentre stavo per dire me ne
sono accorto ma poi sono scivolato
perché me ne sono scivolato a noi girano
anche i vassoi
cielo fatah wow questo far pure
bellissimi
ma chi è così
benvenuto al quiz ok spero che tu abbia
prestato attenzione perché ora sarà
messa alla prova
alla fine di questo quiz dovremmo avere
abbastanza informazioni per capire che a
venti solito alla scuola ultimo per
quali organizzazioni gli argentini
cessano di lavorare
forse tradotto male per quale
organizzazione lavorano voi ve lo
ricordate all'inizio l'hanno detto ma
non ve lo dico io dico di hamsik si è
giusto poi di cosa file diem si abbatte
i criminali stravaganti ma terremo in
mente il finissimo questo che conquista
i voti del mare
poi vediamo che il senso c'era fuori
dalla finestra in classe
potuto essere usato per restringere la
scuola un raggio strizzacervelli uno
psichiatra
un raggio strizzacervelli se non quando
abbiamo visto qualcosa che potrebbe
essere un raggio strizzacervelli fai con
me lo ricordo nel settimo arma dietro a
destra nel primo corridoio o su una
scrivania dell'aula del professor don
booklet sarà una scrivania o che sia
naturali a chi era in piedi più vicino
all'oggetto che abbiamo visto che
potrebbe essere un raggio
strizzacervelli il ragazzo che continua
a raccontare barzellette banani del
professore phone bootleg creditore fosse
stato lui allora
ultima domanda riusciranno le tue
abilità investigative da agente segreto
chi abbiamo visto comportarsi in modo
sospetto il ragazzo che odiava del
barzelletta del professor boom would
like to casa che dà lavoro ad avvenuta
approvazione
bene ora abbiamo risolto tutto che
abbiamo che abbiamo risolto tutte le
informazioni penso che sappiamo chi sia
il colpevole che ha rimpicciolito la
scuola professor bootleg essere solo no
il ragazzo dalle barzellette
professor balboutet
dov'è
eccolo eccolo qui infatti era tutto
verde sembra i greens
esatto sono stato io rimpicciolire della
scuola immagino che tu non mi abbiano
conosciuto quando ero travestito da
insegnante di scuola
per è uguale in casa
telefonato cosa si ottiene da
rimpicciolire una scuola non solo visto
in un film una volta
bra come ride ma
non riuscirai mai a farla franca provate
a fermarmi sim burton's
pronti ok ma dobbiamo salire su gli
aeroplanini
per cappellini
ma d ora ci possiamo
che l'ho perso dai vip
stragelato sono stati tutti noi rope la
roma mi ha fatto cadere
riproviamo allora proviamo un
aereoplanino vuoto però dobbiamo
prendere quelli vuoti e penso ceco
almeno con poche persone perché se no
troppo peso otteniamo no non ce l'ho
fatta di qua da
far
salire problematica
allora sull'aeroplanino riusciamo a
salire quindi forse dobbiamo saltare sui
libri
saggi serio sì siamo fatti ci sei
attaccanti una mini sono fatta gravato
su qualche buon libro ultimamente
per favore fermata prendendo
soggetto questa questa ragazzina da c'è
lombrico con il cappello in aria vi
abbiamo questo che sta investendo con un
rublo nino non è giusto beh continuiamo
il nostro percorso abbiamo da varese a
chi gli ha dato la potente a questi qua
per guidare l'aeroplanino no vabbè devo
fare tutto da capo ma dai ma che non
miri libri ma nel caso tu stai investito
lungo le regionali abbiamo superato la
libreria finalmente
[Musica]
ecco il profeta web la
persistente non è vero
bene vediamo se riesce a superare il mio
esercito di congegni meccanico di non
preoccuparti il loro morso è molto
peggio del loro abbaiare ok che cosa
bella
eva tu sei ancora ferma i libri o non
solo per abbassato a ma che sono ben dei
cani ruby dice che i congegni meccanici
cerca di non farsi mordere ok
proviamoci
no in realtà non mi hanno preso sono
solo caduta giù
poco a poco
ok con calma beh
non è difficile se lo possiamo facile ma
non lo è
[Musica]
no vabbè questo pezzo è troppo
divertente più divertente degli
aeroplanini ma è più difficile ed
inseguono e oltre a loro ci sono anche
gli alunni che si integra cioè non ti
seguono però tifa vince appare persino e
poi c'è anche la vernice che si fa
scivolare
insomma per evitare che possa farcela
anch'io a preparare quello successivo un
casino c'erano tantissimi di canino mio
nonno robot cani capirò nuovo dovete
contare fuori guarda qui alla fine
fontane torri d'aria o non devi arrivare
quasi attentamente non si ferma qui
guarda vedi che salta
vediamo
stavo per dire attento a non chiudere
mai angelo riuscita a superare questa 6
dove si basa sui libri sono qua sotto mi
vedi ciao ciao vado a salvare ok ora è
arrivato di nuovo bootleg hai superato i
miei oggetti vero non importa non
riuscirai mai a superare come scrisse il
mare si è impressionato vero li ho visti
in un gioco online che ho giocato una
volta anni fa è anche lui gioca robles e
c'è voluto un eternità per superarli
quindi immagino che dovrebbe tenere a
bada da un sempliciotto come te a tempo
indeterminato vedremo devo ancora una
volta dirti addio dopo perdente
vedremo mister prince
se riusciremo a superare i tuoi laser io
ho un trucchetto fa basta guardare in
alto
tu
tu tu
[Musica]
l'ultimo super l'ultimo è mia e mi abbia
il robot erano almeno un po figli dice
lei e poi non ho fatto in tempo a
leggere cosa c'era scritto questo è solo
pigro da parte sua dice ok è pigro
[Musica]
riproviamo dall'alto
dai anita e ho finito qui vitale mi ha
superato
dai l'ultimo e poi
stiamo andando in bagno penso proprio di
sì ok ci sono gli agenti
se ci sei in cosa ti ha trattenuto è un
po di laser non importa possiamo
prendere una scorciatoia attraverso i
bagni per raggiungere boucle ok però sta
bruciando il robot brulica al caldo di
robot per non parlare anche della
mancanza di corrente oppure al buio
abbiamo delle torce elettriche ma non ci
è permesso distribuirle gratuitamente ma
insomma non abbiamo molto interventi
finanziamenti ok e vi dai robot e cerca
di passare attraverso le prese d'aria
qui dentro non è le prese d'aria dove
sono
carlo a 36
vedete
no no non riesco a vedere dove l'acqua
perché buy or not piano a ecco loro
illuminano un po con i loro occhi ho
preso questo state davvero difficile
prova a passare da fa
o non ci posso credere o fa troviamo
un'altra strada da fare
eccolo può trovare la strada bravo
provo a raggiungerti poi si vede niente
peruviano a destra sotto l'acqua e
passiamo adesso non li sull'acqua
starà attenta o che non abbia aiutato
evitare perché non riuscivo proprio a
passare abbiamo da qui fa quasi
mai almeno abbiamo salvato però c'è
anche con lo stretto con l'elica che
gira è ottimo come se non fosse tipici
abbastanza non vedo niente
l'acqua ovviamente
chiaro anche sul lavandino forse dal
lavandino detto andare
non ci credo ce l'ho fatta non so
neanche io come aspettiamo vitale eccovi
donne c'è andiamo a salvare tutto
ancora noi si è beccato fuoco qua sono
fatta da in futuro della vita le
pecore
che cos'è
ecco il mio più grande oggetto il
potente di libri giocatore frigo non mi
rassicura di farti fuori freddo
con le voglio fare nelle fogne e qui c'è
lui vuole chiuderci nel frigo vitale
sarebbe anche ponteggiani
esatto qui dietro
c'è un pugno gigante ognuno guarda amore
va bene è stato il significato ancora no
posso passare
non è stato spiaccicato vitale e devi
fare il doppio salto si sono caduto però
bene così può raggiungersi nelle fogne
eccovi tare da youtube
non se ne saprà
che succede
no non è giusto che ci piace un orgoglio
poveri roma ok eccomi riproviamo c'è un
altro cane per l'ambiente aspetta
certo poche e via
no non mi dire che sei stato
anch'io
e io mi metto ma dove siamo abbiamo
ricominciato di nuovo dei primi pugni sì
sì no no non ci credo tutto da capo ma
non tutto daccapo ora siamo qua
è attento anche giovane
ok allora il primo pugno sono riuscito a
passarlo però poi dopo l'altro no
no
no non sbattere con la testa
bello ci credo ma contiamo di cf molto
difficile sono riuscito a passare 1c
caro
prezzo il presente la questa volta senza
che lui sta arrivando venuto è bravo
va benissimo ecco dei lombrichi giganti
che non guastano mai dal libro si
aspetta ci sono degli altri robot là
sopra
no mi ha preso
sono tantissimi e riproviamo ma quanti
ci ha detto tv ci sono anche spaventato
qua ci sono quelli volanti e gigantesca
questi prum
regge su un altro pugno
non ti vedo queste bugie sono di solito
così gravi e quelli che vanno a finire
tutti i finanziamenti dalla scuola
vitale si sono dei semplici che ti
aspettano parlando con sette minuti di
mezzo ho avuto più alto
ma
è così
finalmente è vitale che già buttato
attento fa bisogna avere molto
equilibrio che la
frase lato finalmente siamo usciti da
demoni e allora noi bianco
come siamo tornati grandi ma se la
scuola non importa c'è una scuola non mi
fa passare di là
ecco quale miniatura che carina
quindi noi dalle fogne siamo riusciti a
passare dalle foglie siamo ritornati
grande però la squadra di questa piccola
ecco la scuola è tornata grande anche la
scuola non sia ristretta
eccoli di nuovo sono stato io a sminuire
la scuola
continuavo a guardare quel film da cui
mi è venuta l'idea del raggio
strizzacervelli indovinate un po
abbiamo un interruttore di retromarcia
sul raggio dermot fervore tramite
termoretraibile ma che stai dicendo
quindi ovviamente ho preso anche quello
ok o no ci sta per more traendo un
ingrandito il frigo cibo girato
il frigo gigante grazie a palazzo
invadendo la città
[Musica]
per città con un agente gigante è molto
più favorevole che terrorizzare una
scuola rimpicciolita ok ci vediamo dopo
quando ho visto ti schiarendo dal fondo
dello stivale del mio aggeggio
raschiando a spiagge ti schiaccerà come
un insetto che stai pensando cosa sto
pensato io credo di esserlo
ha ridotto quasi sono dimenticati di
troppo e abbiamo prendere qualcosa dalla
buona fortuna la gente speciale di
trattori andiamo
sappiamo che ce la puoi fare speriamo
vinca o perda tempo pareva allora la
supervelocità quindi
ok ragazzi purtroppo il mio gioco si è
sbagliato e mi ha tolto dal gioco vedere
però per fortuna abbiamo ancora lui
modificare così potevo vedere come
andiamo
io continuo a strage allarme nel
frattempo dai potevo farcela dobbiamo
sconfiggere i bambini che caso difatti
non poteva scivolare
allora ce la possiamo fare basta solo
stare attenti o che cos'è questo
siamo arrivati dal professore prendiamo
la supervelocità più veloce
quindi credo che dobbiamo fare salva
quantum salvato
salta
ma dove siamo finiti sulla metro anno da
questa parte forse dobbiamo andare e
guardi per utente
come fa promettere ancora in vita non
l'abbiamo farvi anch'io
bisogna saltare invenzioni lombrichi qui
ma non è facile anzi care dal pugno
e ora del quiz loro del quiz quindi chi
è il
il cattivo genio che ha messo questo qui
qua per rallentarlo sappiamo bene chi è
il professore suoni dei miei a 10 degli
stanziamenti diabolici ha devastato la
città lasciandola nel suo stato attuale
il infliggerne l'imperatore
chirico gigante chi è il vero fattore
confuso che considera entra perciò armi
e soprattutto confuso
e salto in gigante che faccio da e ci
siamo quasi
mannini
ci proviamo
ma io volevo fare i tuffi non è che
voleva saltare i suoi panini allora
non ho capito
chi sono state mai
stati troppo
questo mi piace tanto
super divertente ragazzini
g
quasi infinite di
[Musica]
gioco
ma non c'è la possibilità di
disabilitare il salto la camminata
veloce ci riguarda è semplice così
forse funziona lo sai forse cds
veramente così
che hanno attivato una balla qui e ora
cosa stasera non lo so dopo 10 mila
strasse lamenti siamo arrivati qui con
la supervelocità il professore
guarda ha fatto cadere lo
strizzacervelli lo possiamo prendere
allora riempì giochiamo lui lo
strizzacervelli bel lavoro evitare dai
un'occhiata al in versione più potente
del team 6 è un dispositivo speciale che
cancella tutte le tracce di un evento
mai accaduto come men in black qua tutto
verrà riportato come era prima ma
ci vuole molto succo per andare
dobbiamo caricarlo scalda andate bene e
dobbiamo farlo una presa elettrica il
frigo dovrebbe fare bene
non sarà facile ma se riesce a salire su
quel cantiere su quel cantiere possiamo
organizzare il take down ok proviamo a
colpire il frigo ok ovviamente del
cantiere ci sono queste la me io la
spettatrice
ok andiamo avanti da qui allora bisogna
stare attenti a non cadere o no
il robot dove la sta cavando molto bene
finora bisogna stare attenti a questi
mandatelo dovevo dire niente ecco
aiuto aiuto
wow wow non ci credo sono simone quasi
non fermerà i maiali in freezer ante che
avrebbe il merito
abbiamo per brno ha distrutto tutto nel
frattempo e frigo
per un pelo è sempre più difficile però
con questi anni
e adesso da questa europa non ho ancora
queste lame e un po pericoloso se
cadiamo da qui però è
che questi che cosa vogliono adesso
scattare credo che aiuto non c'è un
punto per saltare e ne aggiunge un altro
blocco forte non riesco forse lì di
fronte non riesco a capire
wow
il buy abbiamo salvato e adesso la presa
quella gente aveva fatto quello a salire
io ho fatto tutto il giro lui statali ma
dobbiamo colpire il frigo e adesso a lei
ho premuto il bottone
stiamo per colpire il frigo
colpito duro e ora tornerà tutto come
prima non ritiene sia da un look tutto
il mio duro lavoro andato ai dopo grazie
a the bootleg stato arrestato è pertanto
in custodia di hamsik
[Applauso]
non ce l'avremmo fatta senza di te
agente speciale vitale e sai chiude che
ore sono adesso loro di mangiare pausa
da ballo obbligatoria da
mangiare
quelli li imprigionano
grazie ancora agente speciale risale
fino bene agente speciale evitare escape
from completata e ora vi lasciamo con
tre cartellini quindi ricard prevedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite buona visione
[Musica]